- Devant l'entrée
de l'Université de Kaboul,
ces étudiantes se butent à
des portes closes. Des talibans
armés leur bloquent le passage.
"Quand nous sommes eseseses,
ils nous ont crié de retourner
à la maison, qu'on n'avait plus
le droit d'aller à l'école",
dit cette étudiante.
"En nous priv d d d droit
d'être éduquées, c'est comme
s'ils tuaient notre avenir",
ajoute-t-elle.
(cris des manifestants)
Devant l'Université de
Jalalabad, dans l'est du pays,
des étudiamememememes et femmes,
ont courageusement pris part
à une manifestation
pour dénoncer ce nouveau recul
du droit des femmes,
derererereretour au pouvoir
des talibans, il y a un peu
plus d'un an.
Déjà, en mars dernier,
les filles s'étaient vueséeéeée,
et, depuis, les femmes sont
peu à peu effacées de la sphère
publique.
"Les talibans ne veulent pasqus
au développement du pays;
ils veulent que nous restions
à la maison pour faire
des enfants", soutient
cette étudiante afghane.
Les États-Unis ont dénoncé
une décision qu'ils qualifient
de "barbare".
"Cette décision inacceptable
aura des conséquences
pour les talibans", menacececec.
Le respect des droits de
la personne et particulièrement
des droits des femmes est
en effet une condition
essentielle à l'aide
humanitaire et financière
dont a désespérément
besoin l'Afghanistan.
"La communauté internationale
doit intervenir, implore
cette jeune femme. Étudier
est ma seule passion."
Comme des centaines
d'autres étudiantes, elle n'a
pour l'instant d'autre choix
que de refermer ses livres
et espérer un miracle.
Ici Lise Villeneuve,
Radio-Canada, Montréa